- All right.
Well, hello everybody
and welcome to Rockefeller
University's Lab Backstage.
I'm coming at you, not from
Rockefeller, but from my house.
And I'm really excited to
connect you all with one
of our amazing scientists
from Rockefeller, Rochelle.
So, by the way, I'm Jeanne Garbarino.
I am the director of RockEDU.
And so I definitely encourage
you to ask questions,
send them my way if you have any questions
about anything pertaining
to student programs
or getting into research,
or, you know, how to think
about doing research from your
homes or something like that.
These are questions that I love to answer.
So please don't hesitate to get in touch
and we hope that Backstage
is something that you
can glean some really
interesting tidbits from science
and learn about the scientists themselves
and understand that
scientist is for everyone.
Science is for everyone,
and we want to make this
comfortable and relaxed.
And so please do not
hesitate to ask a question
or throw your questions in the chat.
I'll be watching the
chat for you, Rochelle.
So I'll interrupt in
case there's a student
who would like to share
that way, but otherwise,
can I give full permission to interrupt?
Is that okay?
- [Rochelle] Oh yeah, totally.
- Awesome. Okay.
So with that, I'm going to
hand it over to Rochelle
who is going to take you
through some really cool
behind the scenes science.
So take it away.
- Cool. Awesome.
Well,
hi everybody.
Like Jeanne said, I'm
Rochelle, and I just wanted
to first start off before we
really delve into the science
of like a quick introduction
into who I am as a person,
not a scientist.
So I am a graduate student
here at Rockefeller.
I'm actually just in my second year,
so I'm just starting out.
I am originally from Las Vegas
and so kind of more of
like a desert city girl.
And before anybody asks, I did not gamble
my entire childhood, which I guess
is like the first question
everybody always asks me
even when I was 12, but
I did go to casinos a lot
because that's just where
everything is in Las Vegas.
Like if you wanted to go to
the movies or if you want to go
to like the bowling alley or
even like laser tag or stuff.
So I kind of grew up in and around casinos
and I didn't realize that
was a really weird thing
until after I left Las
Vegas to go to college.
So I don't know if that
explains any of my mannerisms
but you can take that
with a grain of salt.
After high school, I
went to Portland, Oregon
for my undergrad, for college.
And there that's actually
where I first began to discover
that I really love science and research.
So it took me, you know,
a little while later.
And so I think it's really
amazing that you guys
in high school are already
getting so involved in research
and having all these opportunities
to be able to talk to scientists.
So like you're definitely way
ahead of the curve than I was.
After college I hopped
around a little bit more,
I decided before I go into graduate school
I wanted to like spend a year
kind of just doing research
kind of as a job.
So I worked in Maryland at the NIH,
which is the National
Institutes of Health,
the government research agency,
and did so much microscopy
and loved it so much
that I decided I really
wanted to do my PhD in something, in that.
And so now here I am at
Rockefeller doing more microscopy
as you might be able to
tell from my background
and then hopefully I'll be
able to share some of that
joint interest with you guys.
So that's kind of a lot
about me and I just wanted
to start off first before we,
again delve into the science
to maybe learn a little
bit about everybody here.
And so I have this kind
of fun poll question
that if you guys would like
to just kind of fill out
really quickly.
And maybe just like five ish more seconds,
you don't have to think
too hard about this.
You won't be graded at all.
Okay.
Well, I think this is
very much kind of in line
with my personal views too.
I love hiking but I would
like, kind of milder hikes,
and actually for the most
part, especially in the summer
where it's like bug season,
I just want to stay home.
I don't wanna be outside.
Oh yeah, I did.
I put in the snow shoeing as something
I've never done before
and I think it would be really cool to do.
So I agree with you Jeanne, so great.
Kind of a fun thing to just
get people interacting.
Unfortunately we will not be taking hikes
for the rest of this Lab Backstage.
Okay, so I guess now to kind
of get into more of the science
which is why everybody is here.
Again, right before I
start really explaining
and showcasing all the
cool equipment behind me.
I wanted to just have
another poll to kind of gauge
what you guys kind of know or
don't know about microscopy
and totally okay if
you're coming into this
and have no idea what
even a microscope is.
'Cause that's the point of today.
So if you guys could just
bear with me for a second
and answer another poll question.
Okay, so I think that was a good amount
and actually really impressive, again,
I came in high school, I had no idea
what any of these were.
So it's already amazing
that some of you have had some exposure.
And to the ones that haven't
had any, about these at all.
Well, I'm gonna introduce
a lot of them to you today,
so you're just in luck.
So I still want to kind of preface
about why does microscopy matter
and why do I love it so much?
and I'm so enthusiastic about it.
And now, like I said, like in high school
I had a lot of great like biology classes,
kind of some general science classes.
Thought that it was interesting and cool
but there was always like a part of me
throughout high school
and college that like,
as I'm learning these
things like, oh yeah,
I know we have DNA.
I know we have this things
called proteins in the cell
that do things and make you be like,
is a reason why life exists.
There's a part of me that
didn't really believe it.
I was like, well, you can't see it.
You don't really know for sure, right?
What if you like were able
to get that small look at it
and there were just a bunch
of these little like elves
kind of like making
sure the cell functions,
however they are.
And so there was just always
a part of me that was like
science is real, but
like, how do you know?
How do you know any of this?
And it really took me until
like college, when I started
kind of having my first
experiences of microscopy
that I was like, wow, you
can actually see this.
This is true.
And everything that people discovered,
even without being able to
visualize it is actually there.
And so it was just one of
those like seeing is believing.
And since then, I'm
like absolutely in love
with just the idea of
being able to see things
that are just so so fundamentally small
and yet so fundamentally important.
And so I wanted to start off today, sorry,
I'm gonna be switching back
and forth from my laptop
to my phone by kind of giving
you guys a broad overview
of how basic microscopes kind of work.
And so here we have this
really dusty old microscope
that no one's really used in the lab.
And this is kind of the
basic light microscopes
that you would initially
see if you kind of took
like a beginning biology course
in college, like in a lab.
And just to kind of really
quickly go over what the parts
of the microscope are
because these are basics
that every microscope no
matter how advanced you get,
basically have and how
it normally functions.
And so over here you have your objectives
and so these are the lenses
that you will actually see
through and put your eyes
on to be able to look
at your specimen.
Over here is the stage of the microscope.
And so I just have a
standard microscope slide.
So usually you'll mount whatever
you want to look at here
whether it's like a tissue
sample, like a drop of pond water
or whatever else you want to look at
that has really small things.
You'd put them on your microscope
slide and you'd slide it
on the stage so that your
sample goes right over
where this opening is.
And you'll see right through the opening,
you'll see this other kind of a lens,
it's called an objective.
And so let me go underneath
the stage for you guys.
And so here is where you
have these objectives
And these objectives are
what actually magnifies
and allows you to be able
to see like your specimen
at a size that you can see,
visualize with your eye.
And see that they have different
kind of magnification abilities.
So here, when it says 40 X,
that means it's able to magnify
something 40 times larger
than it actually is.
And then 20 and then this should be a 10 X
And so, it's through these objectives
that you're actually able
to see a bigger image
of your sample.
But then what else you
need with a microscope
is that you actually need
to have a light source.
And that's what everything on top here is.
So this is a really, really
strong lamp that then shines
a whole bunch of light onto
your sample and then that allows
enough light through into the objectives
and then you're able to view it
through these objective lenses.
And so that's kind of the standard setup
of what a typical light
or bright field microscope
is the term I'll probably be using is.
And it will probably be the
first microscope that you guys
would have experience with
if you want to go into microscopy.
Oh and then this box
here is just the camera,
so you can take pictures.
And so that was kind of the
first microscope I ever used
back in college.
And now I'm gonna switch
over to my laptop again.
Oh cool, Jake says that you
guys have one in your classroom,
so great, you guys already knew that.
Oh and sorry.
I think I forgot to say, but
totally, anybody feel free
to stop me and like either
interrupt me by unmuting yourself
or in the chat if you
have any questions at all
or if I'm unclear or
if I'm going too fast.
And so we started off
with that's like the basic
bright field and that
was the first microscope
I ever kind of used.
And now after that introduction
I wanted to kind of give
again another both a quick
poll section and also segue
into the kind of presentation
I have for you guys.
Sorry, I'm not sharing
the proper screen, here.
And so we have that bright field
microscope and like I said,
we can magnify really small things
but I wanted to take a
moment to really make sure
everybody understands kind of the scale
of the things that we're looking at.
And so this is a really
neat website that Odaelys,
also a part of the RockEDU
team shared with me,
which I think is fantastic for
understanding just how small,
small really means.
And so we're starting out
here with things like a grain
of rice, Times regular 12
point font, coffee beans,
like things we can see
with our bare eye, right?
But if you think about
what scale things exist on
in biology, well you
really have to zoom in
really, really far.
So here now we're starting to
see like things, like amoeba.
So like these things, single
cell organisms that live
in like pond water and stuff.
Then we start seeing single
cells, like your skin cell
that exists within you.
And then we can get
even smaller and smaller
into like bacteria, how your DNA is
and then into organelles of the cell.
And then to like the smallest things
which are proteins that
exist in your cells.
And again, this just really hits home.
The idea that you can see all of that
if you have a powerful enough microscope.
And so these things that I was saying
that I didn't believe actually existed
or were actually happening in your cell,
well now we all have the technology
to be able to actually
look at that and be like,
no, yeah, there it is.
There it is doing its job.
And so with that, sorry,
I am doing a lot of things
at once right now.
With that, knowing now that
we have kind of a sense
of the scale of things, I want
to do another poll question.
So with that kind of
bright field microscope
that I just had, showed you guys,
what do you think the smallest
thing you could possibly see
with it is?
When I do these polls I kind
of feel like I'm on jeopardy.
- [Jeanne] Rochelle, that was
like literally the thought
in my head.
I was like, we should think
about the jeopardy music for this.
- Very in tune.
Okay, great.
Only a portion of people
voted, I'll share results.
Oh, well, we have a wide range of things
that we potentially could
look at and I'll preface this,
a caveat that I think someone,
like poll questions do kind
of have a bit of a trick to it
because there, depending
on what you kind of see
and how you have your microscope set up,
you can see a wide range of
things down to even potentially
a singular protein, depending
on how big the protein
you want to look at is.
But we typically use that microscope
that I just showed you guys.
We usually use it just
to look kind of at cells
and with the right stain, you
maybe you can start seeing
a cell's organelles such
as like the nucleus,
which is one of the bigger ones.
And so now I'll get into
more of the presentation
I have set up.
Before I do kind of more
practical demonstrations.
And so again, just reminding you guys
that here's what we can
see with the naked eye,
here is using that bright field microscope
I just showed you.
The kind of scale that we
can start to see things at
using that microscope.
So really just kind of cells,
maybe some smaller cells
and maybe like a nucleus or so.
And then here is just an example
of like the kind of images
that you really do get from
using bright field microscopy.
And so you can already begin
to see, pointer options,
that you can see individual cells.
And this is actually really
important for a lot of biology
because you can already
get a lot of information
just by looking at how, what
do cells even look like?
Like just from this straight off
I can already kind of
tell like all of these
are actually oligodendrocytes
and you kind of know that
because of their branching off pattern.
And I know that they're really
healthy oligodendrocytes
because they're branching really well
and they're not rounded
up and kind of sad.
And so you already get
a lot of information
about the cells biology this way.
But you can still, like you
can see individual cells
but you can't really
see much detail to it.
And so actually what a lot of people do
when they do bright field microscopy
is they actually have
the addition of stains.
And so depending on what
kind of stains you use
you can start to get a
whole bunch more detail
and start understanding more
about how a cell is actually organized.
And so here is just an
example picture of a section
of plant tissue that
they've stained in green.
I think the cell walls
of the plant tissue.
So each of these should
be one of the cells
and then in green, kind of the cell wall
and then in red they
stain for the nucleus.
So you can see where that is.
And you can even begin to see
these other little structures.
These are all the little sub
compartments of the cell.
And so even though bright field microscopy
doesn't let you see super super small
down to like the atom size.
You can still get a lot
of information on things
that you wouldn't be able
to tell are happening
just with your naked eye.
But still the question is, we
can now kind of get a handle
of like cells themselves.
But what if we were more
interested in more details,
like all these cells kind
of look the same to me.
So I can't really tell what
is what and what's happening.
And is there a way using
microscopy, we're going to be able
to differentiate like
two different cell types
or like be able to even start
visualizing finer detail
within the cell?
And I put that question out
there and the answer is, yes
of course, there is a way to do that.
And that is through using
fluorescence microscopy,
which some of you have
said that you have heard of
or are familiar with.
And so for those of you
who aren't familiar,
fluorescence microscopy, I
just wanted to kind of give
a brief background on what
this fluorescence mean
and how does it work.
And so you have your sample
that you want to look at
and you have these
proteins within your sample
that potentially you want to study
and want to know what they do.
And I have here just kind of a diagram
of like a basic unknown protein.
And I have it in black to
kind of signify, right?
That like, you can't really see it.
You can't really tell, differentiate it
between other proteins around in the cell.
And so it's just kind of
floating there mysteriously.
And so if I do want to visualize it,
what you can do is you add these things
that will specifically find
this protein and bind onto it.
And then that thing will have
something called a fluorophore
and fluorophore is kind of a fancy word,
but really all you have to
worry about or know about
what a fluorophore is is
that it's just something
that will emit a certain color of light,
once you shine light onto it.
And so you have this
fluorophore that then finds
your protein of interest and
you have it bound onto it.
And then you go and you
shine a light source on it.
Just kind of like how I
said that the bright field
microscope works with its lamp source,
but in this case your light is a laser
and you shine this laser
onto the fluorophore
and then what the fluorophore
will do is it will actually
emit its own specific colored lights.
So in this case, green,
and then you can be able
to visualize and detect that light.
And then you're like, okay,
every time I see a green signal
that means this protein is there.
And what's really cool about fluorescence,
is that you can do this
with a whole bunch of different proteins.
And so all of these are
four different proteins
that you want to be able
to visualize in your cell
and you can go through
and you can tag each one
with its own different color.
So like this protein I'll tag with red,
this one I'll tag with yellow,
this one I'll tag with blue.
And then you can look at a sample in total
and you can be like, okay, I
see, like all the green spots
are clumped up here, so I know
that's where this protein is.
And then I have some red and blue
that seemed to be
interacting with each other.
So I know these two proteins
interact with each other.
And you can just get so
much information then
just, you know, in one tissue section
and you can be able to
tell so much detail.
And so I talked about
it a lot in the abstract
and now I wanted to show
you guys like a real
fluorescent image that
I actually collected
when I was at the NIH.
And so what you see here
is actually a section
of a human liver liver
sample that I then stained
with all of these different colors.
And then was looking at
it to get an understanding
of kind of like the
anatomy of a human liver.
And so this has a lot of things going on.
So here's just a more cleaned
up version of that image.
And what you see here is in
pink, actually I'm staining
for the vessels within the liver.
And this is kind of where these
vessels kind of allow fluid
to like move in and out of the liver.
And it helps the liver be able
to do its detoxing function
that we all know the
liver's important for.
And then here in yellow,
what you're seeing stained
is actually blood vessels in the liver.
And then in green, the green
also staining blood vessels,
it also has kind of staining neurons.
So you can even start to
see where all the nerves
in your liver are.
And so just right away,
just from this one picture,
you get so much information
of like, oh, this is how
all the vessels in pink
look like within a liver.
And here's how the blood vessels
kind of position themselves
in your liver section and et cetera.
And so this is just kind of a static image
with a whole bunch of different
colors that you can look at
and get a lot of, kind of
positioning information
about in whatever sample
you're interested in.
But what's also really
cool about fluorescence
is that you can totally use
it in like a living animal.
And so, oh,
sorry.
I think I accidentally took that out.
Let me find.
Okay. Sorry.
I think I was messing
around with this a lot
and then I accidentally
took out that video.
I had a video I really
wanted to show you guys.
Let me pull it up really quick.
Okay. Found it, sorry again.
- [Jeanne] No worries.
- Yeah, so I want to
show you guys this video
because you can use
fluorescence to kind of track
living cells within a living animal.
And so what this video
is, is again in the liver,
they're looking at cells
kind of moving around
within the mouse liver.
And so in green are immune
cells of the mouse liver.
And what, this is somebody that
worked in the same lab as me
at the NIH.
And what she was doing was she
was kind of tracking to see
how do these cells move
around in the liver
and where are they going
and where are they stopping?
And so then here is where you
can start her kind of trace,
the kind of path that each
of these cells are doing
and moving along.
And so there's a lot of things
you can do with microscopy,
with fluorescence microscopy.
And there's so much information
you can get from using it.
So then [indistinct]
intro to fluorescence,
I just have the last poll
question to kind of gauge you,
to ask you guys and have you guys think
about florescence microscopy is I told you
you can start looking at a
whole bunch of different things
using fluorescence but what do you think
is kind of the limit?
Like how many different
things can you look
at at once with a fluorescence microscope?
Okay, cool.
So I think a good smattering
around, but I think
a lot of people picked actually the answer
I was trying to go for,
which is that at once
you can usually see about six
to eight different things.
The thing is that after
you go more than that
in one kind of section,
you kind of just crowd
with too many colors, you
can't really differentiate
between the two.
But I liked that a lot of people
also picked an infinite
amount because what's cool
was in my last lab at the NIH,
the one that I was working
a lot with fluorescence,
there was somebody there
that was developing a
technique to basically turn it
into an infinite amount.
That like we could get over
a hundred different colors
and look at a hundred different things
on the same tissue section.
So everybody's a little
bit right basically here.
Then just kind of chugging along.
Well, actually first I just
want to take a minute to pause
that, if anybody has any questions so far
before I move on to the
next type of microscopy?
- [Jeanne] Rochelle, I'd like
to jump in with a question,
while maybe as they're
thinking about questions.
Are these tissue samples
that you're looking at?
I mean, this is not something
that's alive, right?
- Yeah no, so the image
that I'm on right now
the person is still alive.
So this is a biopsy of a patient.
And so we took a piece of their
liver while they went under
for surgery, and then we
were looking at their liver.
But the tissue itself is not alive.
- [Jeanne] But can you ever
do fluorescent microscopy,
and maybe this would be
an interesting question
that others might have, on
something that is alive?
Like living, like metabolizing, you know?
- Yeah. Yeah.
Sorry, I think maybe I wasn't clear enough
but the video I showed was
actually in a living mouse.
- [Jeanne] Ah, yes.
Thanks, didn't catch that.
Are there other questions out there?
Feel free to raise your
hand or pop it in the chat.
You can continue thinking about it.
Maybe just feel free to interrupt
or chat or raise your hand
and we'll stop Rochelle to
get your question asked.
- [Teacher] I have a
question on behalf of maybe
some of our shyer students
who I know are reading
something called a green fluorescent.
Can you maybe talk quickly
about the difference
between like that and this
kind of you know, staining or,
you know, fluorescent tagging?
- Yeah, yeah, no, that is great.
I didn't want to get too
much into the details
between the different types of
ways you can tag fluorescents
but I think that's amazing
that you guys are reading
and learning about GFP.
Right, so GFP as you all probably know,
originally discovered in jellyfish.
So thank you to them.
And it is actually, it is itself a protein
that gets naturally expressed.
And what's really cool
about GFP is that scientists
have figured out a way to
be able to take that GFP
which is fluorescent by itself and make it
so that you kind of smoosh it
in with one of these proteins,
potentially that you're interested in
and get it so that when this
protein gets made in the cell
it also has a GFP attached to it.
And then you're able to kind of look at it
under the microscope.
And so that's one way of
tagging with fluorescence.
What I have shown right
now is actually using
things called antibodies.
And so these aren't this
kind of fluorophore antibody
picture I made.
That's not, that's something you add,
you as a scientist will
add into your sample.
And then that will find its protein
that it will bind to and recognize.
And then that's how you
look at the fluorescence.
And so that's kind of the difference.
One kind of can get expressed with it,
the other one is something you add in.
But they both kind of give
you the same information.
Okay, great.
I mean, that's a great question
and also a great topic to learn about.
So that's fluorescence microscopy
but then I wanted to
introduce one final version
of microscopy, which is
actually what's behind me here,
and that's single molecule microscopy.
And so here's just again,
another snapshot of that website
I showed you guys in the
beginning of different sizes.
And here, I want to say
that the microscopy,
we were originally
talking about microscopy
that can look at things kind
of at the single cell level.
And then now we're
going to go even smaller
and go into single proteins
and start to be able to look at
single proteins and see what they do.
And so single molecule force microscopy,
this might get a little convoluted.
So totally stop me if I'm
unclear or it's kinda hard
to follow along.
But I wanted to introduce kind of the idea
of a pulling force.
And so we've all hopefully
have played tug of war
or have heard of tug of war, right?
Where you have two things
in between two people
and you're each holding onto
the side and you're pulling.
And you think about what you're
actually doing to that rope
is you're putting energy into it, right?
To kind of pull it apart.
And if you have originally,
this like a really
really tiny rope,
that's really like like
a string basically.
And both of you are pulling really hard.
You probably can pull and
snap that string apart
really easily.
But now if you consider, if
you have a rope kind of more
of what I have shown in my picture here,
that's like a really hefty
rope and that's really strong.
You can pull a lot but it's
going to take a lot more energy
potentially a lot more people actually
to even be able to break that apart.
And why am I talking about
pulling ropes and like energy
and force right now when we
were talking about microscopy?
It's because you can
actually use a microscope
to kind of measure how much
energy you have to put in
to pull something, to be
able to pull it apart.
And that actually is really
really helpful for understanding
how proteins work.
And so basically if you
kind of think about this
like pulling tug of war image
and then kind of move it
over onto this diagram
I've shown here is that
one of the really cool
things about lasers and light
is that it can actually
interact with physical objects.
And so if you have a strong enough laser
you can actually trap a
bead, a plastic bead in it
and be able to move
that plastic bead around
just using the power of light.
And so think about your lasers
and that bead you've trapped
as like the hands on this
rope that are pulling.
And then now that you have
these beads that you trapped
with light, you can then
kind of attach a molecule.
In this case I have DNA
put on there in between it.
And so that's kind of
the rope in my diagram.
And then you can now move those
trapped beads in the light
and like kind of stretch them
apart and put a lot of energy
and try to pull that
DNA so that it breaks.
And like I said before
with, if you think about
like a small string versus
a really giant rope,
the more fragile the DNA is the easier,
the less energy you're
going to have to put in
to be able to pull it apart, right.
Whereas if you have DNA or
protein or some other thing
that you're interested
in, that's really strong
and really interacts really strongly.
You're gonna need to
have a lot more energy
and a lot more force to be able
to pull it before it breaks.
And so being able to measure
how much energy it takes
to be able to break that
thing, that's in the middle
of your beads or in the
middle of your hands
in this diagram, really tells
you a lot about how strong
that DNA, that protein
or whatever molecule
in between it really is.
And so you really get
a sense of like, okay,
this is kind of the properties
of this one molecule
I'm interested in.
And so when you do the
pulling, you end up getting
kind of a graph that looks
like this as the kind of data
from that pulling experiment.
And you don't have to
understand anything about this
other than that, basically the higher up
like vertically you go is just
a measure of how much energy,
how hard you're trying to pull into it.
And that kind of tells you
how much energy it takes
before your DNA in this case snaps.
And so that's forced
microscopy, and you can do this
on a single molecule level,
but what's really cool
about this is you can also
do add in fluorescence
microscopy in with this.
And so that now you can using
fluorescence, the properties
of fluorescence I talk
about, actually look at
and be able to track single proteins.
And so here again, it might
be a kind of a busy image
but all I really want
everybody to focus on
is like this image right here.
And so these are the two beads,
like in the diagram before
that are kind of, if you think
about it as your handholds
that are pulling.
And then in between it, these
little bright green spots
are actually singular proteins.
And so again, really thinking
about the size scale of this,
like you have your cell,
which is like massive,
and then like a little
tiny protein right here.
And that's what you're looking at.
You're looking at a singular protein.
This is like an incredibly small scale.
And you're actually going to
be able to track as it moves
along that rope that you
have in between your beads.
And so that's what these images
are, is just kind of looking
at those single proteins, moving along
and doing their thing.
And so that is single molecule microscopy
and that's what I'm currently doing.
And so I wanted to take
this time now to actually
give you guys a live demonstration
of how this microscope works.
And so before I go into
the live demonstration
I want to take another
minute to just, if anybody
has any questions or anything
they want to bring up.
Nope. That's okay.
Okay, we can get to the fun stuff now
of how this microscope actually works.
So now I'll switch to my phone.
Sorry. Okay.
So first this is what the microscope,
so we call it a C-trap.
And so this is what the C-trap looks like.
And this is the instrument
we use to be able to look
at singular molecules.
And you'll notice it's on
this really special table,
kind of has all these holes in it.
And so this is actually an airsoft table.
And you can think about it kind of like
if you guys have played air
hockey, there's just a lot
of air blowing that keeps this floating.
And this is important
because we want to minimize
shaking motions on the microscope.
And so this is kind of the
little black box and magic
fluoroscope, but I'll
open it up for you guys.
And just exactly like I
said, the different parts
of this bright field microscope,
all of that is contained in here too.
And so if you look really
closely here you'll see
where the objective is,
that middle part there.
This glass thing, that is
where you put your sample in.
So just like the glass
microscope scope slide
I showed you guys earlier.
And then this top part
is your light source.
And so you can see this is
where the laser comes through.
And all these little tubings you see here
are actually connected to syringes.
So syringes that you can put your samples
that you're interested in
looking at, and they will flow
into the glass side and then
you're able to visualize it.
And so I have this prepped
already with some samples
to show you guys.
Before we can do anything though,
we have to come over here,
because every time you open this box,
so this box is here for
your protection actually,
lasers are really cool but
they're also very dangerous
especially the powerful
lasers we're using.
And so we keep everything
enclosed to make sure
that the lasers won't accidentally
shine onto someone's eyes
and damage them.
And so every time you open
the box they'll basically
have this kind of safety
shutoff that shuts off
all the lasers to make
sure no one gets hurt.
And so I have to come in and restart it.
And then now that it's
restart, we're gonna go over
to where the microscope control is.
And so, I mean, first of
all when you kind of see
how this looks, you might think, well,
it kind of looks like a gamer
setup and it kind of feels
like it a little bit with the joystick.
Like I'm just playing Pac-Man basically.
But this joystick is
actually how we control
where the lasers go.
And so I can move it to
catch different things.
And then over here is
kind of like the setup
of what we actually see
as we're collecting data.
And so this is the camera
that's tracking live
what's happening in my glass side.
And then here is just
like a little diagram
of all the different positions
of that microscope slide
of where my sample is.
And in red is actually
where I currently am.
So I can move with my
joystick, different positions.
So now I'm going down to the middle
and then now I'm going all
the way down to the bottom.
And so now I'm going to turn on my laser
to be able to catch my
beads and then I will open.
And then hopefully you'll
start seeing some beads
flow through.
It might take a little bit, a minute.
Oh, this might be a little bit slow.
So now do you guys see all the
things that are shooting by?
So those are actually
beads, my plastic beads
that I'm trying to grab.
And then I just basically
wait here until some of those
manage to find their
way to where my laser is
and then get caught.
Hopefully this will not take super long,
but as we're waiting, again,
if anybody has any questions
or comments they'd like
to throw out there.
- [Jeanne] Rochelle,
what do you use this for?
- [Rochelle] Yeah, sorry.
I forgot to talk about my actual project.
So I am actually studying,
oh, so you can start seeing
beads getting caught right now.
And so I study things,
questions involving chromatin.
And so what chromatin is are actually DNA
and protein complexes, because
your DNA doesn't just exist
as bare DNA in the cell.
It, sorry, I'll switch.
Also exists as DNA that
it's usually wrapped around
different kinds of proteins.
And there's actually a
really complicated level
of regulation of like a whole
bunch of different proteins,
make sure that your DNA,
your genes and your DNA
get expressed only at certain
times versus other times.
And they don't get expressed
like when they shouldn't be.
And so my project kind of
is looking at how do some
of these proteins really
coordinate that regulation
and how do they coordinate in
like a very physical manner.
So do they do it by literally making sure
the DNA gets scrunched
up and is like solid
and can't get opened up
physically or do they do it
by like making chromatin,
making kind of DNA complexes
that are a little bit
more easy to be opened up
and be able to be accessed
by things that then express genes.
- [Jeanne] Cool. Thank you.
- Yeah. Yeah.
So now we are finally catching
some beads, so you see,
this is one of the plastic beads
that's actually getting
caught by the laser.
And I've just moved from my bead channel
up to the DNA channel.
And so that's where I have DNA on my rope
kind of waiting around.
And literally all I do now, you see,
is that I kind of just using my joystick,
move back and forth and try to catch DNA.
And I keep an eye out on this window,
and what this window is showing
me is just like that diagram
I had originally showed you guys.
This keeps track of how
much energy is being put
into my bead and rope system.
And so as I'm moving, you can see
that I'm starting to go up.
That means I'm trying to
pull harder and harder.
So that means that I got something caught
in between my two beads.
And since I got something
caught, that means I can move up
to kind of a channel
that has nothing in it.
I can close all of my,
we call them bowels.
They're basically these tubes.
So they all have openings
that open and close
to allow your sample
to flow through or not.
And so I closed them so that there's not,
basically there's no like,
the fluid isn't moving,
basically like when that will
kind of blow something away.
And so they're closed,
I'm in a buffer channel.
And then now I can pull and
see and kind of look at, okay,
how much energy do I have to put in
before I see something break?
And so right now you can see
I'm putting in a lot of energy,
I'm pulling a lot, pulling a lot.
And then that dip down that just happened.
That was something breaking.
And so then I can take
that point and be like,
okay it broke here at this much energy
that I put into the system.
And so then that tells me kind
of how strong that DNA was.
So yeah, that's kind of
just the general gist of
kind of what I do down
here in the basement.
So with that, I'll stop this video
and come back to the laptop.
And that's kind of what I have
to show to you guys I think,
kind of almost stopped there,
right around this proper time.
But totally, if anybody has
any questions or anything.
- [Jeanne] We see a lot of that
was super cool and amazing.
Yeah. Really awesome.
- I can see the chat
blink and I'm like, oh,
I hope it's good.
And I hope it's not like,
oh, this is terrible.
- [Jeanne] Yeah, does
anybody have any questions,
we'd love to hear from you please?
You know, no question is
too big or too small to ask.
You're welcome to ask even the questions
that you feel might be silly
or whatever, go for it.
- So I think I see this one, right?
What do you enjoy most
while working in the lab?
Oh, big loaded question.
I think I will be honest, using the C-trap
sometimes is the most
frustrating part of my day
because a lot of times
it doesn't work as nicely
as what just happened.
And so I will actually say
that it's not even doing
the experiments that's the
best part of being in a lab.
It's actually being able to be with people
and really have this really
great exchange of ideas
and science and be able
to learn from people
and then also teach other people.
And so I think that's
what I enjoy the most
is just being able to be in an environment
where everybody is super passionate
about the same thing I am.
And we all just like, love
learning about biology
and being able to talk
and like kind of hang out
with people here.
Oh, the name of the machine is here.
How about I'll just write it.
So this machine in
particular is called C-trap
but in general you can also,
if you want to learn more,
you can look up optical tweezers.
So those are actually
what, that's the principle
of using light to trap things,
to grab things basically.
- [Jeanne] Yeah. Great.
I love this question from Naomi.
Are there any disadvantages to the C-trap?
- Yeah, like I said, sometimes
it's very very frustrating
to use, but I think
actually some of the biggest
disadvantages with single
molecule techniques in general
is that you're really taking
your protein or your molecule
out from the cell to
be able to look at it.
And that means you have a lot
of control over that system.
Like I can manipulate
that DNA however I want.
And that's really great because
you can't do that in a cell
but then at the same time, that
means it's in a environment
that's not what it usually is in.
Right, and so you always have
to be careful that the things
that you find and you
discover on the C-trap
really happen actually in the cell.
Otherwise you don't really have
any sort of biological relevance.
Basically that like what
you look at is is only true
when you isolate it and it's not actually
what's actually happening in your body.
So I think that's one of
the biggest disadvantages
but at the same time
you can kind of say that
about every technique in research.
Like there's always the
question of biological relevance
is this actually happening?
So I think that's the biggest one.
- [Jeanne] I Think that's
a really great question
and a really great point.
And you know, if you were to
tell a story about your science
you wouldn't just show data
from the C-trap, right?
How would you kind of, what
other types of techniques
might you yourself pair with
data from something like this
to sort of validate the results
so that it wasn't something
that you saw 'cause if
it was in a test tube,
but something that actually is alive.
- Yeah. Great question.
And I also forgot I had
this whole introduction
in the beginning I was gonna
do and I think I forgot
to do all of it.
But one thing I forgot to mention
is that I'm actually
in two different labs.
So one of the labs is
the single molecule lab
that uses the C-trap and
the other lab actually
uses frogs to be able to
investigate chromatin.
And the reason why I
decided to join the two
is exactly the the problem that
Naomi and Jeanne brought up
is that I wanted to make sure
I have experience in a system
that is able to then make
sure that everything I find
at the single molecule level
actually happens in an organism.
And so what I'm trying to
do is pair using frog eggs
which are also very easily
manipulatable system
to be able to kind of
verify everything I see
on the C-trap, in a frog egg.
And be like, okay, well
at least it's happening
in this kind of biologically
relevant system.
- [Jeanne] I'm sorry,
I'm asking more questions
than you can see.
Aren't they the largest
cell like cell that exists.
So you can see a frog
egg with a naked eye.
Is that true?
- Yes. Yes.
I like to think of that.
They're not as big as a tapioca ball
but I call them little
like balls basically.
They're like this big, but
you can totally see them.
And every time I look at
them, I'm always like, oh,
I really want like bubble tea.
- [Jeanne] Well everybody,
anytime you drink bubble tea
please think frog oocytes.
- Well, the funny thing
is, so I'm Taiwanese.
Like all my family is
from Taiwan and in Taiwan
there's a dessert called frog eggs
because they're like that
size and they're chewy.
- [Jeanne] So, Daniel wants to
know if you've ever dissected
frog eggs or frogs before,
have you dissected frogs?
- No, so what's kind of nice about the lab
that uses the frogs is
that we don't actually kill
the frogs at all.
We only harvest their eggs.
And so I think that's kind of
nice because I feel really bad
about like killing animals
or dissecting them,
even though I understand like we really do
sometimes need to do that
to understand biology
and help with like curing diseases.
But I just, personally if I
can get away from doing it,
I would.
So I haven't dissected any frogs.
I think the last time
I dissected something
was in high school in my biology class,
we dissected a fetal pig.
So it's been a long time for me.
- [Jeanne] Yeah, same.
Other questions before we end our session
with Rochelle and the basement microscope.
- Yeah.
- [Jeanne] C-trap reminds me
of some sort of like, you know,
dance hall kind of like secret programs.
- I was thinking, it's like,
'cause this is all like
soundproofing, I think.
So I'm like, well, I could
do a recording session here.
- [Jeanne] So we have another
question from Yocelin,
please excuse me if I
pronounced your name incorrect.
Why is your research important?
- Another, wow.
You guys are asking really
the big questions here.
I feel like I'm like defending
myself against my committee.
No, I think this is a
really great question
and that's something
definitely every scientist
needs to really be constantly considering
as they do research of
like, you know, making sure
you can convey why what
you're doing matters
and why it's really important.
And so kind of my answer to
it is I'm really interested
in things called like basic
bile, like basic science
which is really just
understanding how do things work
and not necessarily have
much of a disease relevancy.
Like it can't be translated into a cure
for something as easily.
But I think that's still
really really important
because to be able to cure, fix something,
you really have to understand
how it works, right?
First of all, and even though
DNA and chromatin biology
is like a really really well studied field
and a pretty old field.
There's still just an amazing amount.
We really don't understand about like,
how is your nucleus organized?
How do different proteins bind on
and make sure they regulate
gene expression and etc.
And those all translate
directly into diseases.
And so they're not proteins,
I'm kind of studying
and looking at, if you're
deficient or if you have mutated
versions of them there are
like diseases related to that.
And then more just generally
if you have chromatin dysregulation,
so something goes wrong
in regulating a chromatin that definitely,
immediately leads to cancer.
And so there is a direct lead to that too.
And so my kind of, I
guess, broad overall answer
to that is I think this
is really important
because understanding how
your chromatin functions
then makes it possible to
understand why when it goes wrong
it leads to diseases.
- [Jeanne] And I think we
have, thank you so much.
And then we have another
question from Naomi
about the user-friendliness of the C-trap.
- So I think just in
general, it's actually,
it's not that bad.
I think I have definitely
worked with microscopes
a lot more harder to initially get onto.
And part of that is because
this is already a commercial setup.
And so the company has
already took the hard part
and made it as user-friendly as possible.
And so literally, basically
the only things you kind of,
sorry, I'm connected to
three different things
are just your joystick which,
I mean, I think a lot of us
especially the younger
generation knows how joysticks
kind of work and can use it.
And then you just kind of,
there's only a just like a couple
of buttons you can do.
Sorry, I think me showing
you this makes it seem
more overwhelming than it is,
but literally all I ever do
is I just move from these three things.
So I go, I'm at my buffer right now.
And then I go like,
okay, I'm going to DNA,
I'm going to beads.
And then I just move around a lot.
And then that's kind of
like all you really do
with the microscope.
So it's actually really, really
easy to learn and pick up.
- [Jeanne] Do you think that
setting up your experiment
is sort of like learning how
to think about and set up
your experiment is more difficult
than actually using the equipment?
- Yeah, I think definitely
the hardest part of research
is always experimental design.
Because you want to make
sure have enough controls
built in so that okay, if I
see something interesting,
is it actually interesting
or is it because of something
I accidentally did to
manipulate the environment
or vice versa?
If I don't see anything,
does that mean it didn't work
or did it mean that maybe I
just forgot to add something in.
So I need to make sure I
have a control for that.
And I think I still am
not good at making sure
I have proper design and
that's part of what a PhD is,
to really train you to be
able to think like that
and design very well.
- [Jeanne] Yeah. Beautiful answer.
And we have another question from Swapna.
Has there been any accidents
or dangerous situations
that have occurred occurred
because of the C-trap?
Bill says, lasers.
- Yeah, I think the biggest
concern here with this equipment
is the laser, but there haven't
been any accidents in my lab
because like I said, again,
a company is building this.
And so they've already
made sure that they've had
all the safety regulations in
there and they've tested it.
And basically I think I
wanted to stress the danger,
potential danger of lasers.
But then at the same time we
don't want to overstress it
because like there's a lot of safety
built into microscope setups now.
And to really make sure that like,
you won't get hurt through it.
But you should always
still be a little cautious.
The other thing that is
potentially dangerous
about the C-trap is
actually cleaning sometimes,
because we use like bleach
or some like other harsher chemicals.
And if you're just not, if
you're not wearing gloves, right.
And you don't have your proper protection
or you're like kind a
little careless with it
you could spill it on yourself
and that's not great either.
But overall, this is a very
safe machine to work with.
- [Jeanne] And there's a comment
about having an ignition
switch, which is really fun.
- Yeah, just as soon as you open it,
it just immediately shuts off.
So sometimes that's a little irritating.
I'm like, I know that's the
first safety but I'm like,
please I have to keep
turning those on and off.
- [Jeanne] Yeah. Yeah.
And you know, add that being
in a university setting,
especially one like
Rockefeller, we take safety
extremely seriously, lots
of labs, safety inspections.
And you know, we all have to
get certified in lab safety
before even participating in labs.
So there's a lot going on.
Safety is a number one,
but I think it's also,
lasers are also very,
very cool and very fun.
Cool, you know, I'm not
sure how much more time
you guys have to be with us,
but maybe if there's another
question we'll happily take it
or, you know, we can also wrap it up,
if it's nearing the end of the session.
Mr. Sheffield, if you
want to let us know what.
- [Sheffield] Yeah, I think
we have to wrap it up now.
Usually we try to finish by five o'clock.
But thank you so much, Rochelle.
This is awesome.
And Jean really, really appreciate it.
So. Cool.
- Cool. I'm glad.
- [Jeanne] Go ahead, Rochelle.
- I'm sorry.
I just wanted to take a minute.
I actually wanted to ask
you if you would like a copy
of my PowerPoint?
'Cause there's some links in
there to like other things
that'd be really cool
for people to dig in,
to look at images.
And so I would, gonna send that
and then I could also put in
like my personal email
if anybody in the future
wants to know more about
microscopes or even just research,
grad school life, etc.
Totally feel free to reach out to me.
- [Sheffield] That would
be so generous. Yeah.
Thank you so much. I
love the presentation.
I love that sliding scale
to that, that demonstrates.
- That was I think from the
University of Utah, definitely.
Odaelys was the one that was like, oh,
you should totally talk about
this, which is very cool.
- [Jeanne] Really well done.
Well, thank you everybody.
We're so glad that you
can be with us at RockEDU
for the Lab Backstage program.
Please feel free to check out
some of the other programs
that we have.
We're always hosting this and that.
A smattering of things for
the science enthusiasts
like yourself.
And if you were interested
in doing research with us
at any point, please do.
Both our Lab Backstage, sorry,
our Lab Jumpstart program
and our Summer Science Research program,
we're already sort of in process
with those programs for this summer.
But if there's interest for
you, for following summers,
we should be back in person.
So that should be great too.
And yes, just keep in touch.
We have newsletters,
follow us on Instagram.
We don't have a TikTok, mostly because
nobody knows how to
use Tik TOK on my team.
Sorry, everybody.
But please do follow us
on Instagram at RockEDU_.
Thank you again, Rochelle.
Thank you to you all for
being generous with your time
and your questions.
And we hope to see you soon.
- Thank you everybody.
Hope everybody had a good time.
- [Jeanne] Okay, take care.
- [Sheffield] Thank you.
All right.
Have a great one.
Thank you all so much.